britain's prince andrew who has ended a
sexual abuse lawsuit by agreeing to a
reported multi-million dollar settlement
queen elizabeth's middle sign will not
have to answer questions under oath
about virginia guffrey who claims to be
a victim of alleged sex trafficker
jeffrey epstein mts taeyab has more on
the end of what's been a devastating
scandal for the royal family
i have no recollection of ever meeting
this lady
none whatsoever you don't remember
meeting her
for someone who so defiantly denied all
allegations including having ever met
even 17-year-old virginia jafre prince
andrew is now poised to donate a vast
sum of money to her victims rights
charity in court documents andrew
acknowledged jeffrey's suffering calling
her an established victim of abuse and
said he regrets his association with
jeffrey epstein his longtime friend and
convicted child sex abuser ujjafre says
trafficked her to the prince cbs news
legal analyst ricky clemen
this may not be an admission of guilt on
the part of prince andrew
but it goes to the same issue what
virginia jeffrey needed was to be
acknowledged as a victim of sexual abuse
no admission of guilt no apology and
most crucially no longer having to face
a court deposition ahead of a jury trial
on claims he sexually abused and raped
jaffray while she was still a teenager
roya nica is the sunday times
newspaper's royal editor to see a member
of the royal family involved in a
full-blown trial and have depositions
taken would be even more damaging than
we've already seen this case be
make no mistake this has already cost
prince andrew dearly gone is his prized
position on palace balconies gone are
his ceremonial military honors and while
he may still be a duke gone is the title
of his royal highness stripped from him
just weeks ago by his own mother queen
elizabeth for cbs mornings i'm impious
taeb in london